you've both
been a part of your fair share of
reboots and also long-running franchises
so when this opportunity first came your
way
what was it about the fugitive in
general that made you guys think that
there was more to mine
in that concept oh my gosh uh there's
a lot of reasons why this was so
attractive uh i was
a huge fan of the original um i don't
look at his big shoes to feel i i think
it's
just a great play on the theme of
an innocent guy on the run and people
just
tend to love the underdog story uh and
then working with quibby and this new
platform
jeffrey katzenberg i've been a
fan of keepers for as long as i've been
watching film
um and stephen hopkins our director uh
just
knocked us out of the park yeah for me
i was a huge i thought the idea of
quippy was so interesting
um being able to create content that was
10 minutes long was really exciting
taking the idea of the fugitive which we
shot as a movie
uh and being able to create
kind of entrances and exits for scenes
that would
uh break up uh the film over a period of
time
all of that was exciting really wanted
to work with boyd stephen hopkins
uh he and i did the first season of 24
together
uh couldn't wait to work with him again
and the script was really well written
um so as as boyd was saying i i
you know i was a huge fan of the
harrison ford
tommy lee jones uh version of this story
uh but this is the post-9 11 version
uh terrorism had hit american soil that
is a part of the show
uh technology has grown so much
uh that we have cameras on every corner
of every street
uh that plays a huge role in the show
and so i felt that we were doing a new
take on it
but again the story centers around
societal's desire to rush to judgment
and that we often do not take our time
to find out
the real facts of the situation before
we form our opinion
and i think that that in itself is a
very cautionary tale
given how those themes have changed from
let's say 1993 until now what about
just from when you shot the fugitive
versus
now given everything that's happened in
the world and specifically in the
country
over the last couple of months are you
now watching the finished product with
different themes and ideas taking i
don't know having even more value to
them than when you actually shot the
thing
well it's you know i mean the the world
has changed dynamically
uh you're dealing with a worldwide
pandemic you're dealing with a whole
social movement
uh black lives matter and more
uh across the nation uh you're having a
federal government
dictate policy that's never been
dictated in this country's history
uh you know so all it makes you think of
as well
be an interesting second second series
to make you know
uh if if as artists you draw upon
what is happening in the world around
you i would have to expect that
most artists around the world whether
they're painters writers actors or
musicians
uh are are having visceral reactions
to to what is happening some positive
some negative but
but visceral nonetheless i did want to
go back to
the 93 movie because i know you're
playing a different character
here kiefer but you are following up an
oscar-winning performance from
tommy lee jones it's one of my favorite
performances of his
even though it's a different character
and you got to make him your own
is there anything that he did in that
movie that you used as a source of
inspiration for your version of the
character well there were two things
that he did
uh and and part of it was the script and
and part of it was the way he
interpreted it but he was incredibly
funny
he he was so sarcastic uh
and sarcasm generally is the kind of
humor uh
that is embodied by someone who is very
cynical
uh and and both of those things
uh were integrated in our script as well
but i really wanted to lean into those
because people who have been chasing
criminals for 35 years
are cynical uh and that that's a real
danger because that's where they can
make their mistake that's where they can
just think they've seen it all
but that aspect of the tommy lee jones
character was something that
i just i could watch it today and and
enjoy it as much as i did the first time
i watched it in the theater
uh there are very few actors on the
planet
i believe that can do that that well um
so like boys said you don't try and fill
someone else's shoes you try and create
your own footprint
uh and hopefully an audience will enjoy
it
i've only been able to see four chapters
i don't want to spoil anything but i do
have to ask
is there anything akin to the i didn't
kill my wife i don't care conversation
in this version
not as direct but yes there there are
moments
where i'll have that conversation with
other people within my department uh
and and and and i'll leave it at that
and then maybe you'll be pleasantly
surprised down the road i'm looking
forward to finding those moments
um i know you had mentioned earlier that
you shot this
kind of like a movie but was there
anything over the course of the
production
process that challenged both of you in a
unique way with your craft and just
telling stories
i don't think there was any hindrance at
all working
on this project and sort of of how it's
given to the audience in these segments
it didn't affect anything i prepared for
this role as a
for a series or a film um
i think it really comes down to the
dynamic of of the editing
and the sort of evolution of the
platform of how they're being
sort of rolled out what about working
with nick santora on this because i've
covered a bunch of
uh quippy movies and shows and most of
the time when i talk to people it's
their first time experiencing a quibby
but
you guys had the luxury of working with
i mean i guess now
emmy nominated nick santora for uh most
dangerous games so
did you feel his influence kind of
helping you out with the format
well he's an incredible writer this
doesn't happen to me very often but
uh stephen hawkins had called me up and
we had done the first
season of 24 together and our great
friends and
uh and i think he's an extraordinary
director um
and he said well i've got this thing and
would you read it and i did i read it
and he said well what do you think and i
said
i'm in if you want to do it i'll i'd be
thrilled and he said well
call me back tomorrow and we'll go over
your notes
and i said i'll go have a drink with you
but i've got no notes
and he said what i said i love the
script i think it's fantastic
that doesn't happen very often you know
you might have a note because you don't
understand something or
something's not clear i had none and
then he said well i have a couple notes
and i said good don't change any of my
stuff though
and uh and he uh i just
that's such a rare thing to happen uh to
to find a piece of material that you
feel that strongly about i just think
he's an extraordinary writer
what was it like jumping back on set
with him i know it's been a while since
he directed you in 24 but was it kind of
just
you know picking up where you guys left
off in that sense i think you're so
focused on what you're doing at that
moment
you kind of stay focused on that um
but with stephen you know stephen has a
unique way of directing
uh that if you're halfway through a
scene and he's not engaged he really
will
yell out you're boring me and
there's very few people that i've worked
with that are confident enough to tell
you that in the middle
of shooting a sequence and it always
makes me laugh but then it always gets
me fired up to go back so
he he and i just have a nice way of
working together where
he makes you want to really reach down
deep and do your best
so what's an example of a moment where
he says you're boring me then what's his
follow-up what what's his uh
his note giving process to kind of steer
you in the right direction
well he finally stopped doing it while i
was holding a gun because i pointed it
at him a couple times and said is this
exciting you more
no it's just he does it in a funny way
uh
that's just that's kind of a traditional
pat way to do this come on
think a little harder we have a very
comfortable way of working together
uh and i think boy do you have a similar
experience right yeah i
i think uh you know you can get a little
fatigued during a day
or a take something like that and i
think
uh what kiefer is is also getting at too
is just that stephen has a lovely way
to check you in line but uh in an
endearing quality
that kind of keeps it rolling and keeps
light keeps it playful uh
because yeah there's nothing malicious
about steven he's he's there to get the
best out of you
and and like you said fire you up and
you're gonna like i do have a little bit
more let's get down and
pull this out did you guys swap predator
stories at all
oh yeah we did yeah we did um
what what a what a franchise to be uh
involved in i think they actually um
there was a dancing video with um that
he also directed the promo
uh told me some inside stories about
that and just
um yeah i think every predator has got a
story
i would imagine thank you guys so much
for your time today
big congrats on the series thank you so
much be well